ja das war mal ein thema das wir seit
etwa zehn jahren den seit 2010
eigene energieerzeugung
abgestellt haben zunächst mal die
kernkraft dann wir hatten die sicherheit
von kernkraftwerke der welt
dann haben wir die kohle sozusagen
aufgegeben und haben gedacht wir könnten
das andere mit sonne und wind machen und
in wirklichkeit man uns aber nicht die
wahrheit erzählt denn in wirklichkeit
ist in der gleichen zeit natürlich der
erdgasimporte immer stärker nach
deutschland aus russland forciert worden
weil das weiß jedes kind aber die
bundesregierung hat uns das nicht allen
erzählt dass so ein windkraftwerk ich
war ja mal selber windkraft unternehmer
ich hab so viel dünger hergestellt
steht eben öfter als es ist dreht das
ist leider zu 20 prozent des jahres
vertrages
eines jahres also 8700 hatten ja also
ungefähr 2000 stunden dreht das vollers
und bei der sonne ist das noch viel
schlimmer die solaranlagen haben 1000
stunden und nachts wir wissen haben die
scheint die sonne nicht also braucht man
natürlich immer dann wenn erneuerbare
energien die fluktuieren sind ein backup
wieder batterien speichern oder weil es
noch nicht haben gaskraftwerke oder
kohlekraftwerke und da man sich
entschieden die kohle wollen wir nicht
und da finde ich ist schon der erste
fehler gewesen der bei jetzt einfach
weitergemacht wird es gibt eine
deutsche- von deutschen ingenieuren
entwickelte technik die gab's mal in dem
schwarze pumpe in brandenburg nicht in
der ehemaligen ddr
war ja alles auf braunkohle ausgerichtet
und da hat man entwickelt eine co2
abscheidetechnik und das abgeschiedene
co2 konnte man dann in die tiefen da
wohnt man gas gefördert hatte zum
beispiel oder unter der nordsee
verpressen dann wären wir das thema los
geworden und hätten einen wahnsinnigen
effekt auf die welt gehabt denn wir
hätten den chinesen sagen können was mal
auf jungs wenn ihr weiter eure kohle was
wir verstehen ihr habt viel kohle und
ist billig wenn ihr die weiterverwenden
wollt dann müsst ihr aber diese technik
anwenden denn wir wollen mit dem co2
runterkommen aber das hat man nicht
gemacht weil das natürlich irgendwie ein
bisschen schwierig war man muss den
leuten das ja erklären und sagen wir
wollen das co2 unter dem boden aber ich
habe mich noch erinnert wer das
angestoßen das kann aus schleswig
holstein
der damalige oppositionsführer
ließ robert habe ja das ist noch mal
sagen da ja damals gesagt
schleswig-holstein möchte nicht der
abfalleimer seien für co2 aus
er hat uns denn abhängig gemacht von
russischem gas das war doch auch gerhard
schröder und ich meine sie sind auch in
der spd also die spd war doch ja massiv
beteiligt an dem an dem drama in dem wir
uns jetzt befinden dass wir jetzt in
einer unglaublichen abhängigkeit zu
ändern weil sie sie beschuldigen ja alle
waren bis natürlich würde ihnen auch
widersprechen in der frage dass es dann
der erste fehler war die kohlekraftwerke
abzuschalten sondern oder oder gar auf
kohlekraft zuversicht der erste fehler
war die auf atomkraft zu verzichten tja
ich eure erlösung und ist sehr
interessant wie sie sich an der
atomkraft vorbei lavieren hier jetzt
gerade in
die atomkraft gibt es nur dann nicht
mehr wenn sie die augen schließen warum
genau so genau so wie es wie china jetzt
demnächst noch einmal 250
kohlekraftwerke bauen wird baut die
ganze welt atomkraftwerke nur
deutschland er jagt seine preise in die
höhe und sagt wir wollen darüber nicht
sprechen das ist ein kleines kind dass
die augen zumacht und sagte ich bin
nicht reagiert das heißt wenn wir nein
sie wollen ja ernsthaft über die energie
krise reden dann müssen wir natürlich
noch zur verfügung haben wenn wir jetzt
über den winter den nächsten winter
kommen wollen nützt es mir nichts zu
sagen natürlich bin ich für neue
kernkraftwerke die sind leider
abgestellt worden in den letzten zehn
jahren in der regierung merkel und
deswegen muss man eigentlich sagen dann
wenigstens das was wir noch haben
vielleicht sogar noch die drei die im
letzten jahr stillgelegt worden sind
reaktivieren und dann endlich auch neue
technologien der kernenergie
entwickeln aber es hilft uns nicht mehr
jetzt zu lamentieren
11 12 sind die alle abgestellt und ich
halte es auch für falsch ich habe es nur
geht das ja weiter wie kann man jetzt
diese krise lösen und dann sage ich
erster erdgas fördern zweitens kohle
weiter und drittens die in thailand um
kraft die wir haben weiter betreiben und
ich gerade am 31.12
aber die bundesregierung lernt nicht
dazu das ist das problem sehen sie heute
hat die umweltministerin gesagt wir
wollen ein verbrenner verbot für 2035
das will die durch beispielsweise geht
es um das event nach widersprochen ja
aber er hat gesagt wir machen das nicht
jetzt hat er sich hoffentlich
überrascht okay
wir wissen dass strom jetzt knapp werden
wird weil wir eben nicht genügend
erzeugungskapazität haben und dann
ausgerechnet in dem land wo es knapp
wird sagen wir wo wir die technologie
von des verbrechers entwickelt haben
sagen wir wir wollen das alles jetzt auf
e autos machen aber der ist ja noch
nicht erschlossen das ist ja sagen
dienste haben wir sehr gespannt wer sich
da durchsetzt ich hab dann wieder gehört
dass die minister und lamb gesagt
natürlich bleibt dabei da wollen wir
gucken ob da wirklich dann auch die
koalitionsfrage darstellt und sagt das
machen wir mal zum koalitions thema ich
halte das für dringend erforderlich weil
wir haben immer noch einen stoff der
nicht so knapp ist gas ist wahnsinnig
knapp das wird uns in diesem herbst
ausgehen aber haben wir noch genug öl
und in der situation dann auf strom zu
gehen da kann man nur sagen jeder wer
demnächst ein e fahrzeug sicher oft muss
sie muss ich damit rechnen dass das auch
dann nicht angefangen von gestartet ist
ja auch vor allem die ängste die sich
die bürger jetzt gerade machen wenn sie
jetzt auf den nächsten winter blicken
haben sie auch angst bürger dass das gas
aus geht natürlich habe ich angst als
bürger dass das gas ausgeht dass wir
unseren energiebedarf nicht mehr decken
können weil da hängt ja viel mehr dran
da hängt nicht daran ob ich jetzt warmen
dusche oder kalte dusche sondern dahin
mein komplettes leben im zweifel auch
meinen arbeitsplatz dran und erst werden
die unternehmen betroffenen unternehmen
seien es sein dieses kritische
infrastruktur aber da kann man auch
wieder diskutieren was ist denn kritisch
was ist er nicht kritisch am ende des
tages wird es darauf hinauslaufen dass
anleger werden sie länger liefert werden
das weiter zahlen ja genau ich darf in
der apotheke da ist warm aber natürlich
weiß ich das doch gar nicht auf was für
ideen dann nachher ich sag mal unsere
regierung noch kommen das heißt ich muss
ja auch als arbeitgeber gegenüber meinen
mitarbeitern der fürsorgepflicht
wahrnehmen und die kann ich nur wenn ich
auch entsprechend energie habe wenn wir
alle mit bluthochdruck heizen könnten
dann wäre
mein blutdruck gerade
massiv hoch wenn ich sowas höre dass in
anführungsstrichen im herbst und im
winter keine energie mehr da ist aber
ich glaube es kommt so langsam an heute
hat die vorsitzende des deutschen
gewerkschaftsbundes frau fahimi gesagt
hat die bundesregierung ermahnt dann hat
gesagt diese krise auf die wir uns jetzt
die wir zu rennen darf nicht auf dem
rücken der arbeitsplätze und
arbeitnehmer ausgetragen sie hat leider
noch nicht den nächsten schritt getan
was müsste sie denn tun ich würde gerne
helfen und das haben wir jetzt gerade
getan indem er sagt ja dann muss die
vorsitzende deutschen bewirkt
wir müssen
und ich frage mich bereuen sie denn
etwas rückblicken dass sie sagen mit dem
wissen von heute hätte ich war es anders
gemacht das fragt man sich als bürger
wenn man auf die politik das frage ich
mich immer ob man auch selber kritisch
mit sich ins gericht warum willst du
nato und ich muss ganz offen sagen mir
fällt dann nicht viel ein was ich hätte
anders machen sollen
die kanzlerin ja aber
das sagen auch andere dass bei der
ganzen sache zu sagen dass nicht alle
auch viele sagen auch zu viele ja das
ist richtig
also das ist außerdem schon schon fast
25 jahre her aber
auch ein bisschen gemein ist der verlauf
der kamera gekleidet werden gibt es aber
die die frage die sich jetzt wirklich
stellt ist zum beispiel in hamburg wir
haben ein großes kohlekraftwerk das
gerade abgestellt worden weil ich jetzt
haben wir wirklich am ende werden die
bürger
stromrechnung bekommen bis der arzt
kommt ja
oder apotheker ja und das geht doch
alles nicht das heißt wir müssen doch
mal jetzt mal innehalten und sagen okay
alles zu seiner zeit im augenblick haben
wir uns dafür zu sorgen dass dieser
wohlstand den wir aber nicht kaputt geht
das nicht zusammenbricht denn wenn am
ende 5 millionen arbeitsplätze weg sind
die kommen erst mal so schnell wieder
wie 16
er schaut sollte seinen
wirtschaftsminister mal sagen dass man
auf da wir draußen diskutiert dass wir
erdgas haben ich möchte dass genau
wissen und ich möchte gerne eine
unabhängige gutachten haben und ich
möchte gerne dass das ein gesetzentwurf
gemacht wird der das fracking verbot auf
und zweitens möchte ich ganz gerne dass
der forschungsminister die abscheidung
von co2 aus kohlekraftwerken macht und
das dritte ist und selbstverständlich
müssen wir jetzt die brennelemente
bestellen oder bestellen lassen durch
die energieversorger das am ersten
januar nächsten jahres nicht diese drei
kraftwerke die kernkraftwerke abgestellt
werden und unsere noten nochmal
vergrößern denn ich sage voraus diese
bundesregierung wird am zweiten januar
an daran gemessen werden wie sicher
unsere arbeitsplätze sind und wie sicher
wir uns versorgen können denn am ende
wird folgendes passieren sie werden
stromrationierungen kriegen wie in
südafrika auf der einen seite wird ein
für drei stunden abgestellt auf der
anderen seite erreicht und er ist
stromrationierung geben wird wenn wir
das nicht wenn wir das so machen wie das
jetzt im augenblick werden wir damit
rechnen müssen der e.on chef hat gesagt
wir werden es nicht zum blackout kommen
wenn man den blackout verhindern sind
totalzusammenbruch dann müssen sie wenn
es strom strom knapp ist ihm zu teilen
das heißt sie müssen sagen der stadtteil
kriegt heute morgen der andere
stadtteile haben wir euch süd kriegt ihn
übermorgen und in berlin ost klingt dann
und so waren dann können sie das
vermeiden aber stelle sich mal vor was
wir dann sind wir sind dann sozusagen
auf dem status eines entwicklungslandes
und das wird während die bürger nicht
hinnehmen und das wird die regierung am
ende ihre kosten die ist es die kommen
nächstes jahr im januar noch mal hier
hin zu analysieren dann schauen wir was
für ein job die regierung gemacht hat